et
[Musique]
le dernier chat d'oc a été nommé
ministre de la population
il est chargé de pondre des oeufs de
façon intensive mais il n'est pas assez
éduqué le chat d'oc population dans son
petit ministère 1
ça lui prenait quand même pas mal de
jours pour compter jusqu'à 4 et pondre
un oeuf
alors la direction s'impatientait shadow
co pour essayer d'augmenter le rendement
était en train de mettre au point un
truc spécial qui permettrait avec un
ministre de pondre 2 et pourquoi pas
trois ou même peut-être plusieurs eu moi
même temps à lapoutroie la maison qui
ont été délicates mais le produit
lui-même et des garanties sans danger à
quelques détails
[Musique]
est-ce que ça allait marcher
- - la direction obs luz attendaient
l'heure de la ponte du ministre peu à
peu approché mois eh bien oui ça
marchait première fois quand on dit deux
à la fois épique 4 et bbc
[Musique]
la lune se couvrit d'un grand manteau 2
de shadoks
et quand le temps fut venue des premiers
commencèrent à vouloir avec l'homme
[Musique]
ça y était il était sauvé l'espoir
renaissait
[Musique]
population shadoks repartait une
population de shadocks tout neuf qui
partiraient vainqueur cette fois à la
conquête de la terre et qui sait
peut-être même aussi de l'univers
[Musique]